hey guys hope install it so we can't
tell I'm in New York I've been here for
about a week now but reason we came here
for a Nintendo switch event which if you
guys miss those videos I post a few of
them at the press event I got hands-on
with an event which is coming out a more
3rd those are the youtubers here that
was Freddy and doing Devon a PP Austin
with here a lot of people here
I played Mario Kart for so long I
probably played for like two hours last
one we played for this toy and guess
what I wanted so excited oh my god I'm
so pumped up one of the first places
that I went and when I got here we went
in God oh my god
I mean
I also had some problems getting to New
York all assessments light which in
return that I didn't pack everything
that I needed so I had to do a little
bit of shopping
[Music]
not know how to do it really brought in
hiding it a really cool time lapse of
the smell we can't see it so what
tell me up there look at that you can
see the my hair fruit it's cold
you guys new here I had a very very
early start to my trip when I was
traveling I always lose my wife
everything was about everything that I
did if they have a pic Adams definitely
getting a pinkie removed big sizes are
they always are so much smaller
no not the same I mean it's pretty
incredible
[Music]
knowing even harder now but the tests
are almost complete I'm ending up
staying longer in New York connected to
something activity felt that's why the
items are very very important I thought
I have my items I'm getting so my eyes
so in hopping books I went shopping and
I thought only clothes I was planning to
pack for New York and then got home and
I had a bunch of men's clothes in my bag
and clearly that's us we probably think
that I should have noticed I was in a
hearse you may attempt to do what they
put in my bag and then I was like in
shock I was in Fisher Peter kind like
whoa so they've actually have to return
of things so now I'm here again to go
get the clothes that I didn't get Kylie
I love him so much I'm I I just recently
we can the biggest Carly classes and the
lady not never but like I'm in a pan so
I can't claim the ever title
put on a new big fan we gotta find the
tile though I didn't unboxing over the
tiles
and I was so excited we talked about
them and you think you are going against
one forgot them forgot them along with
everything else we got them we got oh
I'm so excited
they also went to check out one of the
new Apple stores is here in New York
downstairs
of the Apple store it looks exactly like
it is because if I'm in tennis which can
you believe the van antennas which are
here the amplifier this is actually
really cool if you have a child or you
are a child this is awesome so this
right here it's like a little mirror so
it allows you to see what you see here
so when I put this to where it should be
it knows
again wow you guys the future is here I
am pretty big apple can I look down and
I was like oh the heck is it I did not
even know it still cannot be late 2014
I forgot my macbook charger and they
didn't have 100 they sent to the 5th
Avenue store which is here we are here
the 5th Avenue store right now but it's
going to be under renovation very soon
so I don't think it's actually open 24
hours we're going to go inside it's been
such a long time since I've been here
this is the Apple sort of Joey and I
came to a nice dance back you may notice
but there is a snapchat torx behind me
it's a spectacle I have been funding
magenta spectacles and I thought the
line was short so I went in got a pair
also got an extra pair for use at the
spectacle storm so excited
right now no he'll be under 21 fine Wow
Wow Wow I'm so excited to give away give
away its back yeah I think I should be
very clean we're about to go off on my
first time using the snapchat Bob's you
guys been falling for a while you know
that we waited outside for a very long
time Cinna Monica beautiful all right
here we are
[Music]
all right we got him so some guy wanted
to return to to get a different color so
I swapped out the coral for appeal to
Syria what we did is so exciting you
know so it looks like I've got an extra
pair of black spectacles if anybody
wants them I'm always really bad at this
so I'm going to go with sweet me on
Twitter and then screenshot that you
love to comment on this video and tell
me why can you want them now we're going
to go to the Apple store what a great
great street this is this little corner
is just incredible touch up close you
were I wonder along the renovations will
pay you gets to be like on a long thing
another building we're moving it here
oh yeah that's an apple of whose secret
let's just let them walk in and then
walk back out
so many memories in the store I love
this store
you're making fun of me now so it's a
grow this Apple store inspired Rosana
and eyes gingerbread sugar in video it
was like glass houses in the chatter ok
that's it I don't need anything so we
can go back up now
I think you speaking the heparin whoo
maybe I'll see if I can take a little
peek inside I'm here yeah right base of
renovation
holy moly well I can't wait Siri set my
alarm for a year I'm gonna give it a
kiss goodbye now they don't like when
you touch it I have actually kissed it
before and got yelled at so yeah keep
the lips off the store I wish I was
staying for another couple days I can
see the opening of this store
Oh June 2 days January 20th what's today
I remembered a this game I'm lost track
what else did I do in New York mana
mission the whole food here in New York
anyway I want you within your own ma say
I haven't had any in several days and I
think Oh God
where's where's the rebel berry hmm
come on a lot of problem I only see blue
I seem to have lost my wallet let me see
if I can locate it oh I hope I can find
it let me use my tile where's my purse I
lost it I can't find it
do you hear that oh let me do you on map
find it Oh oh my goodness I found my
birth
the thing I'm still worried a lot of you
guys have some questions about tile how
long is the battery life is a
rechargeable no it's not they have a
replacement program so you can basically
send them in and they'll send you
another one I believe there's some other
stipulations and you probably have to
pay for it not 100% sure but I was
looking into it because that is one of
the biggest complaints with tiles is you
can't recharge the battery but there is
a warranty up to a year which is kind of
cool there's another thing that you guys
suggested trackable tracker
I think er ACK are that one you can
actually change the batteries and it
does have GPS built-in so I do want to
try that out like a new a side-by-side
test and see which one is better one of
the best features is if you do have your
keys with you and you press the tile it
will ring your phone that for me is
going to be extremely extremely helpful
Oh oh my goodness I miss you so much my
sweet doggy oh look how good you look
she might have the same color here oh
gotta get just a cream color well I'm
back from New York that's the end of
this vlog came to watch a Manny give my
mouth oh it's official if he's eight or
nine days too long and he's officially
mine the option papers don't make sense
so with that if you bumped your computer
or you tripped over the charging cable
you wouldn't completely entirely lose
your computer to the floor so far knock
on absolutely everything I have yet to
have that happen to me I so all God I'm
putting it out there the universe I'm
sorry